[Music]
good morning everybody seven o'clock
here in the uk very welcome to spend
your breakfast with us here at sky news
this morning willfully negligent and
taken your foot off the break perhaps
not the headlines the health secretary
would have hoped for this morning after
announcing he's no intention of
triggering plan b coveted restrictions
right now
but does that promise hinge on more of
us getting our boosters we'll ask the
health minister ed argher
on the show shortly plus we'll get the
view of a clinical nurse with more than
three decades of experience to see if
she agrees with sadie javid that the
pressure on the nhs
is manageable for now
also this morning the former prime
minister tony blair warning of a fourth
wave and calling for half a million
boosters a day we'll speak to him just
after nine o'clock on the programme and
a slippery slope could a covered fueled
winter cause europe's ski industry to
wobble once more 8 30. we're going to be
speaking to an instructor about her
hopes and fears for the season plus the
telegraph's travel editor claire irvin
will tell us how rising cases could
impact your winter getaway it's thursday
the 21st of october
willfully negligent doctors hit out at
ministers for not stepping up their
covered measures as the government tells
people to get their boosters so we don't
risk going backwards
i'm in oxfordshire to find out if
british farmers think a trade deal with
new zealand is a raw deal for them
a service this morning to mark the
centenary of northern ireland's
foundation but her majesty won't be
there after being advised to rest
where they're live
i'm at a food bank in east london as a
new study reveals that the number of
low-income households in debt has
tripled since the pandemic began
nine months after he was silenced online
donald trump launches his own social
media platform called truth social to
take on big tech he says
we report exclusively on how banks are
investing in and loaning two businesses
linked to deforestation
and intense streams of lava continue to
shoot from the la palma volcano an
eruption that's destroyed thousands of
homes and forced several thousand people
from their homes on the canary island
and after a bad art celebrations is the
world's first ultra-realistic robot
artist is freed after egyptian customs
officers arrested her
thinking she was a spy
[Music]
well it is thursday doctors have accused
the government of being willfully
negligent for not triggering their plan
b coveted restrictions now to slow the
spread of covert 19. the health
secretary sanji javid has warned we
could see a hundred thousand cases a day
and on the slow uptake of booster jabs
he called on people to get on to avoid
us all to get one i should say to avoid
us all going backwards emma birchley
reports
for 19 months kimisoko has hidden
herself away
terrified of catching kovid
she's chronically ill with various
conditions that have weakened her immune
system
and while for many life is returning to
some kind of normality that certainly
isn't the case for her
there's compassion fatigue
so the numbers aren't getting us as
round up emotionally to where we feel
the civic duty to do our part as they
did in the beginning it's frustrating
because some people's livelihood hinges
on your adherence
to
common decency
but the number of cases has been rising
for over a month and there are warnings
that the health service could be heading
for the most challenging winter on
record
i represent doctors and what they're
telling me especially those in hospital
is that
the pressures are really building up
we're seeing uh ambulances now queuing
outside a and e and it's not even the
height of winter so i'm not really sure
what we what more we need to watch and
wait for now is the time to put in place
measures to reduce the spread of
infection
increasingly the onus is being put on us
as individuals to do the right thing
with the business secretary and chief
medical officer among senior figures
pushing a message of personal
responsibility
but the fact is since mid-july there's
been no legal requirement in england at
least to wear a mask at all
if it's a legal thing then people will
like be afraid of the penalties and
other things they will start wearing
again how do you enforce
um people wearing masks on trains
or on buses how can you enforce it you'd
have to have a law i would abide i would
obey the law but i would think a lot of
people wouldn't to buy it not now
they've had enough of lockdowns and
wearing masks but elsewhere in the uk
mandatory mask wearing has never gone
away and in scotland where the case rate
is lower they're still worn in schools
we've also had massively delayed
vaccination of adolescents and very poor
role out compared to say scotland so for
example we have about 15 percent of 12
to 15 year olds who've been vaccinated
compared to about 50 in scotland
the message the government keeps pushing
is get vaccinated and when offered book
your booster but with the colder weather
looming it seems less and less likely
that that will be enough
emma birchley sky news
joining us now health minister edward
hello to you thank you for joining us on
the program this morning covered death's
rising 21 in a week but no plan b yet
why not
well we continue as you would expect to
look at all the data a range of data a
range of factors and as the health
secretary made clear yesterday the nhs
while under huge pressure at the moment
and i pay tribute to all those working
in it it is a sustainable pressure at
the moment the key thing the key which i
suspect you may come to a little bit
later is what's what's the difference
between now and for example last time
which was i think back end of last year
end of december beginning of january
when we saw these high levels of
infection rates is of course the vaccine
program which while not completely
breaking has hugely weakened the link
between infections and hospitalizations
and sadly deaths i wasn't going to ask
you that in fact i was in fact going to
ask you about sir patrick balance the
chief scientific advisor who said act
when you think you don't need to
so that and you know if you interpret
that that would be act now because you
don't think you need to well i think
what what patrick's saying there is
you've got to look ahead at what this
disease does we know that you have a
lead time of two weeks roughly between
infections and hospitalizations and
further two weeks between sadly
hospitalizations and deaths in the most
serious cases but the key change there
has been
the vaccination program which has
altered the dynamics since
i first started talking to you about
this year and a half ago i think yes but
so what patrick's
21 in a week well let me just answer the
patrick point a little bit and then i'll
come back to your point there if i may
um i think what patrick's saying is is
always look the future consider when is
the right moment to act and do it before
it's forced i don't think we're at that
point yet but we will continue to revere
kevin on the death point that you um
raise yes sadly we are seeing
hospitalizations and deaths going up
that's a reflection of the big number of
infections but if you just take a data
point a few days ago i think about the
15th is the data off top of my head
where we had
about 450
infections per 100 000 in our population
and you saw about 700 people i think
admitted to hospital on that day and
sadly just shy of 100 deaths if you then
look at when we last had that level of
infections which is about the back end
of last year you were talking about 3
000 people
being admitted to hospital
and considerably more deaths around 600
deaths so that's the difference i use
that it's not a perfect analogy but it's
an illustration of why
the infection rate
is relevant but it's not uh it doesn't
pull through into those deaths and
hospitalizations in the same way well
let me ask you this and how bad does it
have to get
well i think what you're asking there i
can entirely understand where you ask
the question but it's not it wouldn't be
appropriate an arbitrary figure x number
infections x number of hospitalizations
we need to look at all this in the realm
we need to look at the death rate
absolutely we need to look at that
booster rollout program the vaccination
program vaccination rates in young
people the 12 to 15 year olds because
we're seeing in that school age
population that's where we're seeing
actually the biggest increases driving
these infections so it's not that sadly
and i can entirely understand why you'd
like a simple clear-cut answer sadly
it's not it's my benefit for your
viewers of course
but you know how bad does it have to get
better and you know that i always do try
to answer your questions
but on that one i can't give you a
simple here is a sort of black and white
answer here's a binary line because it
takes there's a whole range of factors
we'll take into consideration but you
did say there is a point to act
but you don't think that is yet so when
is that point well it depends as i say
on a whole range of factors but the
reason i say not yet and why the
secretary of state sajid javid said that
yesterday is because we are seeing
pressure in our hospitals we've got a
challenging win to come we see that
every winter if we didn't have a cover
pandemic i suspect you'd have me on
normally to talk about winter pressures
in the nhs
and flu now we see that coming with cova
with flu
and a resurgence and flu and other
seasonal
infections
so we are seeing pressure in the system
but we're not seeing unsustainable
pressure at the moment if you take
hospital beds just as an example we've
probably got at the moment around
95 000 hospital beds in our systems
smaller than it has been because of
infection and prevention measures
about 7 000 or so those are occupied by
covert patients
but we've still got around 6 000 that
are currently unoccupied now they're
unevenly distributed but we have got
that capacity so at the moment we're
saying the nhs is
a difficult situation but we need to
look carefully at all those and that's
one of the factors i'll be looking at we
know how quickly that can change we had
the head of the nhs confederation on
yesterday he said
is the government absolutely barking mad
you need to get ahead of this and you
know by not implementing plan b you're
not getting ahead of it well i know
matthew um well i've worked with him
since he's taking up that role and i
have a lot of respect for him personally
there's a butt coming well i disagree
with him on that particular point it's a
timing point um you know what is the
right time or sometimes matthew saying
we should have done it yesterday others
will be saying you don't need to do it
for a long time and that's what that's
why this is a difficult judgment with
multiple factors as you'll appreciate
let's talk about boosters instead why
are people not getting their boosters
so there's a mixture of factors here um
firstly there are five around five
million people who are entitled to jabs
who haven't had the first or second job
my message to them get your jabs you're
eligible you're entitled please do it
it's the single biggest thing as sajid
said
yesterday that we'll avoid that pressure
becoming unsustainable avoid
the need for any further restrictions
but to your point about
boosters we've delivered about 4 million
there are i think just over two million
more invitations that are around two
million more invitations that are going
out as we speak to people to do it so
we've got the capacity in the system
we've got the
we've got the vaccine we've got i think
over two and a half thousand venues
where people can be jabbed across the
country at the moment
part of it is encouraging people to take
up that job and i think going something
i think you raised on your program
yesterday morning
and we've made a change which is it's
not just about waiting to be invited if
you get to the six months plus one week
go on the national booking system and
book yourself in but there's also the
other factor which is a a slight uh
which does like not delay but phases the
roll out which is the jcvi's current
advice which is
don't have your booster until six months
afterwards so if you look back six
months that's um that cohort is starting
to come through now is there a slight
lag yes there is um and that's why we
have taken the step we have so how do
you book online both online you go on we
can go on the one ring one one one
or you can go on the um nhs website i
booked my jabs when i was eligible some
months ago from the first time you go
and you log in your details your nhs
details it shows you're eligible and
then it shows the venues you can book
into so it's very straightforward we
don't need to go uh to see your doctor
you you can do it if you have a vaccine
if you get to that six months plus one
week so
until that point wait to be invited but
if you get that and you get a week
beyond it to allow for a little lag i
think this is a point you raised with
quasi yesterday so
yeah but have we changed policy here at
sky news for you i don't think it's
about changing policy throughout this
pandemic you've seen we've sought to be
and i've tried to be pragmatic and we're
on your show on others people of
your viewers and others highlight saying
well this bit doesn't quite um work for
us or it could be amazing we look at it
and we'll see if we can do something
that makes it easier for people glad to
hear it um you're presently jabbing i
looked at the figures for the boosters
over the last couple of days about 200
000 people a day tony blair former prime
minister saying that needs to be at five
hundred thousand a day are you going to
be able to reach that target well i've
since really hoped we've got the
capacity to do it we've got the people
do it we've got the how do you do it so
have you we've got the job and exactly
that so that's why um you know i'm here
to answer your questions i'm also here
slightly to sort of exhort people if you
get the call if you're invited please do
do it because that is the the best way
not only of protecting yourself and your
friends and family further but also of
easing that pressure and allowing us to
keep keep going as normal or as normal
as we can and if you don't um you know
was the underlying uh comment from the
health sector yesterday other measures
will have to come in place i'm reading
uh in the telegraph this morning there
could apart from being a plan b there
could be a plan c no mixing of
households at christmas time well i have
to say i saw that story on my uh on my
way over this morning that's um not
something i'm aware of i checked it out
and i'm told there isn't that that is
not a story with foundation of course as
a government you
look at as we've done with our plan b
alternatives and ways that you might if
you needed to
start easing that pressure but the
specifics of that and what was uh mooted
in it as i understand exactly i'm afraid
on my way in um this morning about
limiting household mixing things like
that in a sense going back is that it
isn't something that is being um
actively considered my viewers i would
think this morning would think why did
ministers keep coming on the show and
saying that's definitely not going to
happen and that's definitely not going
to happen when you don't know what's
going to happen well i don't i think it
is it's rare that i've ever been on your
show and said something whether it's
definitely going to happen or definitely
not going to happen
and the reason i do that is because you
will always understand me if your
viewers want to try and get as we said
at the beginning a clear yes or no
answer
and sadly in this space um in a lot of
these questions that isn't possible on
lockdown you ask that specifically
i'd come back to
comments made by kazi and others there
is no intention to reinforce we did it
last year and one of the reasons we did
it at the beginning of last year and
during last year is because we didn't
have the vaccine and the latter lock
down we did but it was still being
rolled out and it's very early so we
didn't have the vaccine we didn't have
in the early stages these treatments rem
deserver and the new treatments where we
announced yesterday that we're uh buying
in advance which help avoid people going
into hospital so that's what's changed
and but i come back to the key message
please everyone please do get your jabs
if you're invited yeah i was a bit cross
this morning minister i have to say when
i was reading about kovacs
and we have contributed to kovacs just
looking at the figures
we promised uh to donate 80 million
doses
we've delivered so far only seven
percent of that and worse than that we
have taken half a million doses from
kovacs which is designed for countries
that can't really afford them third
world countries places like south africa
that have only had a four or five
percent uptake what are we doing taking
vaccines from kovacs well there's two
points there okay firstly there is a a
little bit of attention here we're
seeing where you know your question is
quite legitimately saying have you got
the vaccines yes we have was the answer
but there's attention there with a lot
of people saying make sure you get those
boosters make sure you've got what you
need here equally quite legitimately
people saying well we're not protected
until everyone's protected and that
includes the poorest nations in the
world so quite rightly we should be
donating do we need to do more to drive
that donation drive the pledges we made
and deliver on them
yes we do but i'd also highlight in the
context of kovacs because we as a
country were one of the countries that
kick-started that with huge financial
investment at the beginning and we also
as a government again invested in the
oxford az vaccine up front and striking
the deal that it should be delivered at
cost price so i'd entirely take your
point that when we make a pledge we do
need to deliver on and we need to keep
making sure we focus on that but equally
for this i would just highlight
the money we've put in is the fact that
we took half a million doses we were
criticizing the canadians for taking a
million doses we have taken half a
million doses from kovacs that should
have been going to countries that need
it more and we are putting we put the
financial resources into kovacs to get
it going it's acceptable to do that
though is it mr i think i think there's
always a balance to be struck here and i
suspect that in the the case of how that
worked
it will have been simply a matter at the
time of here's how the process works if
you're entitled to it this is what's
been done you're absolutely right though
we have a moral obligation to support
all those around the world with these
vaccines we've done it in the
development of the programme we've done
it in the investment in the azerb
vaccine and the reason we do that and
the reason why we need to deliver on our
pledges in terms of donations to kovacs
and indeed broadly our work through
gabby and other programs is because
we're not completely protected we're not
completely safe and no country is until
the world is yeah
so i don't i don't dispute um your point
about just how important this is and the
moral obligation unless i think that's
why we continue to face will we
potentially take uh vaccines from kovacs
again can you rule it out well on my
understanding is we have the supplies of
vaccines we need both as i said to you
for our booster program for our young
people 12 to 15 year olds in our program
there so i think our folks should be on
getting those jabs in people's arms when
those arms come forward but also in
parallel on getting additional jabs too
not ruling it out then through kovacs i
don't anticipate that being the case i
think my understanding is that that is
something that occurred historically um
we've got we've bought a huge number of
vaccines tribute to the vaccines task
force we've got the vaccines we need how
do you feel morally about doing that
about taking vaccines from people that
um needed them well what i'd come back
to is the track record we have of
investing in the vaccines to get to to
get it for those people yeah and we are
donating um i'm just donating and then
taking and i said no i suspect okay what
happened there i'm not familiar with the
exact detail of what happened i think
this is a story that's emerged this
morning it has i'm sure you'll be asked
about it again ministers and i suspect i
will be but the the key point i would
make on that is that i suspect can i be
honest with you i suspect what would
have happened is at the beginning of the
pandemic when vaccines started becoming
available later on in the pandemic i
should say there would have been a
mechanism whereby there were allocations
drawn down i suspect that was probably
just done automatically i take your
point it's not something i would wish to
see happen because i don't think we need
to because we've got our vaccine stock
so i would look to see us not doing that
and supporting all those countries the
very best of our ability um it's going
to be a difficult day for you today
along with the family of james
brokenshire
it is and and he was a regular on your
he was program and so you all know
fabulous man exactly you all know as do
i as a friend of his normally what a
lovely man he was um
but as we heard in the tributes um
uh yesterday in the chamber um he was a
very nice and very decent man but no one
should ever mistake that for james being
a pushover or two nice he was an
incredibly competent um and effective
minister and so um as he's it's his
funeral today and and we're all thinking
of him and kathy and the family
our deepest condolences to the family if
you would thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you
and just a reminder if you want to catch
up on any of that interview or indeed
watch the programme when you are out and
about this morning then of course you
can you can find us on the mobile app or
you can go to our website if you prefer
and go into our live blog to watch the
program live
and you can also catch up on the
interviews on my twitter as well and
that is at k burley
still to come on the programme for you
this morning most of us have been jabbed
but how well are they working at 7 30
we'll discuss vaccines and booster doses
with professor of immunology at imperial
college london professor danny altman
[Music]
a new way to treat dementia at 7 45
we'll meet the scientists behind a study
that used infrared light to help treat
those suffering with the condition
9 45 is buying a house about to get even
harder it looks like mortgage prices are
on the rise we'll ask a finance expert
what on earth is going on
more on that breaking news from
overnight in the uk and new zealand
agreeing to a new trade deal aimed at
eliminating tariffs as high as 10
percent on a wide range of goods is
causing concern among some sheep farmers
that they could now face increased
competition from lamb imports our
business correspondent paul kelso is
joining us live from a sheep farm in
whitney in oxfordshire good morning to
sun just rising behind you there paul
what's the view on this trade deal
yeah morning k i'm at a farm in
northmoor in oxfordshire where they farm
sheep on pasture that can't really be
used for anything else they take a great
deal of pride in turning out around a
thousand lambs a year here some of them
they sell at the farm gate others they
sell through the supermarkets and they
are concerned they believe this trade
deal with new zealand is effectively
going to give
a the factory farming or the certainly
the mass farming might of new zealand 12
000 miles away at the ability to
undercut the produce they make here to
what they say are the highest possible
standards in the uk market now this
trade deal with new zealand is the
second the uk has struck since brexit
it's significant following the deal with
australia announced earlier this year
because it's been built from the ground
up it doesn't just roll over the terms
of an old eu trade deal and it's a sign
the government will say of britain's
ability to strike these deals as an
independent trading nation after brexit
but nowhere in the british press release
which talks about some of the benefits
to uk consumers cutting tariffs on
imported wine and honey for example
british cars going in the other
direction and not facing import taxes
nowhere does it mention agriculture and
that might be because agriculture
appears to be the trade-off that the
british have allowed here in exchange
for those uh cuts to new zealand imports
and for british people to be able to go
and work in the services and
professionals to work more easily in new
zealand they've allowed access
tariff-free over a 15-year period to new
zealand farmers it's the same as the
australians race and that will be the
criticism of this deal that that
trade-off of british agriculture has
been given away too cheaply
okay thank you
service of reflection and hope is being
held at st patrick's church of ireland
cathedral in county arma to mark the
centenaries of partition of ireland and
formation of northern ireland the queen
was expected to attend but has cancelled
her trip after being advised to rest
our senior island correspondent david
blevins is in amar ahead of today's
service it was a surprise david that she
isn't attending
yes they are very disappointed here as
you would expect okay a very good
morning from arma it is to the best of
my knowledge the only city in the world
with not one but two cathedrals of saint
patrick one roman catholic and the other
protestant and it is here to the
anglican cathedral the church leaders
have come together to organize what
they've described as a service of hope
and reflection marking a hundred years
since partition and the formation of
northern ireland and they're very
disappointed that they've lost not just
one but two heads of state from the
congregation today her majesty very
reluctantly yesterday cancelling what
would have been her first visit to
northern ireland in five years on the
advice of her doctors the 95 year old
monarch will instead be resting at
windsor but the irish head of state
president michael d higgins had already
declined his invitation on the basis
that he didn't consider the wording of
this event politically neutral now the
irish foreign minister simon coveny will
attend we understand the british
government will also be represented i
think it is worth just noting that it
would be impossible to mark the
formation of northern ireland without
acknowledging that it only came into
existence as a result of the partition
of this island but this comes at a
difficult moment bearing in mind that
the fresh brexit tensions over the
border have placed a strain on
anglo-irish relations okay thank you
thanks a lot and david
donald trump is launching a new social
media platform to stand up to what he
calls the tyranny of big tech the former
president who was banned from twitter
and facebook earlier this year after
accusations he incited the 6th of
january insurrection at the u.s capitol
says he plans to share his thoughts with
the world on truth social mr trump has
also revealed that he's forming a new
company called trump media and
technology group to rival tech giants
like twitter and facebook
in a statement he said we live in a
world where the taliban has a huge
presence on twitter yet your favorite
american president has been silenced
this is unacceptable i am excited to
send out my first truth on truth social
very soon
and the former u.s president bill
clinton has said in a video on social
media that he's glad to be back home
three days after being released from
hospital mr clinton was diagnosed with a
urological infection which spread to his
bloodstream and spent five days in
intensive care mr clinton has urged
people to keep a check of their physical
health
take the time to listen to your bodies
and care for yourself
we all have work to do
and each of us
is an important role to play
in life
and in the immediate future
i for one
i'm going to do my best to be around
to keep doing the most good i can for a
long long time
looks a bit poorly doesn't he now a
large-scale study of households on low
incomes has revealed the extent of the
debt crisis impacting the uk's poorest
families the joseph rantri foundation
estimates that the number of low-income
households in debt has tripled
since the pandemic began
i sure is at a food bank for us in east
london this morning hi aisha good
morning tell us more about this report
from the foundation
[Music]
well this research really just
highlights another impact covert 19 has
had the joseph rowntree foundation we're
looking at the households in the bottom
40
of income in the uk and out of 11.6
million households 3.8 million in
arrears like you said that's triple the
number when you look at figures from
before the pandemic and people largely
behind in things like rent council tax
and gas and electricity bills it's meant
that places like this the felix project
have been busier than ever over the
course of 2020 they delivered more than
21 million meals out to the community in
london now if we take a look at some of
the numbers from this study and look at
those worst affected the data shows that
55 of families with children have fallen
into debt
the figure is the same for households in
london but analysis shows that those
from black asian and ethnically diverse
communities
have been hit the hardest with 58
in arrears campaign groups are saying
that financial pressures for these
households aren't debating and that the
situation could get very much worse very
quickly but the government said that
things like pla their plan for jobs will
help upskill workers and provide
opportunity for people to get into
well-paid work and in the meantime
there's also things like the household
support fund available for those most
vulnerable and universal credit
supporting millions
okay thank you
uh the study estimates 55 of families
with children have fallen into debt as
we were hearing there from aisha and as
a result of that i she will be inside
that food bank for us a little bit later
on today
now she could very well be the future of
art as we know it but the world's first
ultra-realistic robot artist has hit a
snag ahead of her latest show this is
ada
who's named after mother of computing
science ada lovelace and she's due to
open her latest exhibition at the great
pyramid of giza but when she arrived in
egypt she and the sculpture
she created were held by customs
officials they said the modern uh the
modem forgive me that she uses and the
cameras in her eyes could pose a
security risk
luckily ada was freed yesterday after 10
days a few hours before the exhibition
was due to start hopefully she'll be
able to paint brush the whole experience
off see what we did there
ha ha
still to come striking scenes from la
palma as its volcano continues to spew
lava at an alarming rate with no sign of
an end
there you go
the eruption that began more than four
weeks ago has forced the evacuation of
more than six thousand residents and
destroyed thousands of homes on the
canary island an expert yesterday warned
that an end is difficult to predict
predict i should say is it's more
intense than previous eruptions the last
one back in 1971.
at the same time here's the exact moment
japan's mount aiso erupted yesterday
morning releasing smoke and debris more
than two miles
into the sky
their meteorological society says there
were no signs of injury or damage but
warned citizens to stay away for fear of
a second eruption pretty dramatic stuff
wasn't it
now as covert cases surge we'll ask an
expert how long the vaccine is effective
for and the role boosters can play all
of that
[Music]
again everybody doctors have accused the
government of being willfully negligent
for not immediately triggering their
plan b coveted restrictions to slow the
spread of covet 19 that's as cases
continue to surge but the health
minister edward argher has told us this
morning that for the time being the
pressure on the nhs is sustainable
the reason i say not yet and why the
secretary of state javid said that
yesterday is because we are seeing
pressure in our hospitals we've got a
challenging winter come we see that
every winter if we didn't have a cover
pandemic i suspect you'd have me on
normally to talk about winter pressures
in the nhs and flu now we see that
coming with kobe with flu
and a resurgence of flu and other
seasonal
infections
so we are seeing pressure in the system
but we're not seeing unsustainable
pressure
tomorrow's here good morning tomorrow
don't panic mr marin yes plan a all the
way is what the government is saying um
they say that the pressure in the system
is not unsuspect unsustainable despite
the nhs leaders yesterday warning that
it was because although mr argher said
there are 6 000 unoccupied beds in the
nhs of course they may not be where you
need them at the right time so we're
already seeing parts of the nhs
including the doctors union the bma
saying it's willfully negligent of the
government in england not to bring in
more measures the number 10 point out
there of course the trade union but
still they are saying that we are at
that point now the government say we are
not at that point now although
interestingly satya javid said yesterday
it was very somber tone as he said cases
could reach a hundred thousand they
don't think we'll be in remotely the
same situation in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths as we were
at this time last year because of the
vaccine but he did say look be cautious
wear your mask if you can mix outside do
if you want to take the lateral flow
test before you go to a gathering do so
perhaps we're edging towards plan b
already without it actually being said
but as to the idea that there might be a
plan c beyond that with restrictions on
indoor mixing the minister's firm answer
was no there isn't okay tomorrow's day
at nine o'clock this morning looking
forward to it thanks very much indeed
well the backdrop to the health
secretary's winter warning was another
49
139 new coronavirus cases reported in
the last 24 hours a further 179 people
have died which takes the total within
28 days of a positive test
239
031 deaths
almost 43 000 more people have received
their first dose of a vaccine just under
33 000 have had their second dose that
brings the total number of people who
are now fully vaccinated to 45 million
and just over 199 000 booster vaccines
were given in england in the last 24
hour period taking the total number of
doses to more than four million figures
for other parts of the uk were not
available so 200 000 booster doses
yesterday we'll be speaking to the
former prime minister tony blair who
says we need to get that figure up to
half a million a day if we are going to
fend off more restrictions leading to
christmas
joined by danny altman an immunologist
at the imperial college london hello to
you thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning uh professor um
no plan b
as yet uh how are you feeling about that
i feel very worried i don't i don't mind
whether it's termed a b c or d
all i know is that this the new um the
new slogan of living with the virus sits
very uncomfortably with how we normally
practice medicine and medical research
in this country because we normally and
don't tolerate avoidable deaths that
would be easily avoidable with quite
simple mitigations
what is it about
people not wanting their booster do you
think because a
slight blame game this morning from the
minister saying
we've got the jabs we just need the arms
to put them in
yeah it's very hard for me to say where
the real bottleneck is um whether it's
people not coming forward or whether
it's it's hard to access
i think it's probably a bit of both i
think we've done less well than some
other countries in terms of getting um
boosters into people all i can say if
there's anybody out there who has any
doubts whatsoever please just look at
the data um so i'd point them for
example to the publications from israel
where they were troubled like us by a
surge from delta breakthrough cases they
had a massive program of nationwide
boosters and they crushed that curve so
let's just do it
a lot of older people don't want the
pfizer booster um that that's
anecdotally from from my experience when
i was working in a hub they'd if they
came and the uh vaccination that were
being offered was fisa rather than
the astrazeneca they didn't want it they
went away some of them and then came
back when astrazeneca was available if
you've had an astrozenica you need to
have a pfizer or you're advised to have
a pfizer as a booster just to explain
you know this i'm just explaining it to
the viewers as a boosters then you're
mixing up the two vaccines so what are
we going to do if older people don't
want to have pfizer
well maybe we have that discussion and
you know all of this has been a work in
progress hasn't it um so there's quite a
lot of fancy immunology that's been
being worked out um you know building
therapy as we fly so there's a slight
aversion to giving things like
astrozenica adenoviruses over and over
again because of the risk of building up
antibodies that might actually block the
functionality of that vaccine
thus the choice to go with pfizer um but
it is a work in progress
and and about these two antiviral drugs
that we heard quite a lot about
yesterday at the news conference in
downing street um
great step forward
i think it's enormously exciting these
these are the breakthroughs that we've
waited for now for what 19 20 months
because you look at the the cell biology
of a virus like this and at the moment
we focused on one achilles heel haven't
we the the the the binding of um spike
to ace two and hitting that with
antibodies but there are many other
points where we can hit it and we just
wait for this moment and this looks like
a very big breakthrough
how long do the vaccines how long are
they effective for
yeah again a work in progress isn't it
because if you'd asked me this question
oh a year ago i'd been fairly gung-ho
and said most of us were probably good
for one to two years then delta comes
along and it's such a game changer and
breaks through our defenses and it looks
like people are becoming vulnerable
after six months um so we have to be
very um fleet of foot to keep looking at
the data and reappraising
and other variants potentially on the
horizon especially people starting to uh
get involved with with international
travel again um do you think we're going
to be in a position where we have to
have potentially a booster every year or
maybe even every six months
i
hard to say i really hope not um so
we've all been watching the variance of
concern coming around the curve and i
think many of us thought that delta was
kind of peak variant and there weren't
many more up the viruses sleeve in terms
of changes it could make um let's hope
that the rate of new variance coming
along is is slowing down and this might
all settle out in due course let's hope
what's your biggest worry professor
oh my my biggest worry is that we um
is that we we take our
lose control
do this thing of learning to live with
the virus instead of saying no these are
people's lives this is avoidable there
are simple measures here um
masks ventilation a bit of distancing um
let's let's just grapple with this and
not be one of the countries where we
where we um chief in the value of life
and don't care about um avoidable deaths
as much as say mainland europe let's
let's do the job properly
sounds like a plan b to me
call it what you like
um what about children under the age or
as young as five being vaccinated where
are you on that
i again i i feel like we slightly fooled
ourselves in this country by being
with our pride in our great vaccine roll
up but we hadn't really rolled it out to
all the people whose lungs this virus
could live in and so in terms of
population immunity that's a job only
half done
i see no reason not to keep rolling out
the vaccine through the age range
because as you well know all the cases
at the moment or many many cases are
overwhelmingly spreading out of
school-aged children
so let's just do the job properly
okay professor good to talk to you
thanks for your expertise as always
well those youngsters will soon be able
to get a covered 19 vaccine in the
united states 28 million jabs soon be
rolled out at pediatricians offices
local pharmacies and potentially even at
school as well it comes as the new york
mayor bill de blasio declared all
municipal workers must be vaccinated or
risk being placed on unpaid leave joined
now by a professor of infectious
diseases at the university of california
and that's peter ching hong hello to
thank you for joining us on the program
so five-year-olds being vaccinated tell
us more
uh well okay the meeting is next tuesday
at the fda well the where they will
review the data from pfizer
showing that at one third the dose that
is 10 micrograms they get an equivalent
immune response to older uh individuals
ages 16 to 25.
uh fewer side effects at least initially
and so it appears good to go i think
most people are behind this including
the american academy of pediatricians
the already school mandates are proposed
for one year from now in california and
hopefully other states will follow
yeah i mean we often hear a lot here the
other side of the pond about
anti-vaxxers in the united states who
who think that it's barbaric um to
particularly vaccinate children
yes so there were protests uh a a couple
of days ago in california where there
was a
sit out where school kids stayed at home
on their parents uh desires and
protested in major cities in california
the mandate proposed one year from now
but if you look at the data only about
one-third of parents actually
vehemently uh oppose any uh vaccinating
vaccination of their kids age five to
eleven uh about one-third we'll say
they'll go out immediately and vaccinate
their kids and about 40 percent will
watch and wait
um
not the case in new york city really is
it because the mayor there is saying to
emergency workers that if you don't blue
light workers i should say if you don't
have two vaccinations you're on unpaid
leave
yes um but we do know that vaccine
mandates have been working in in the us
uh take for example
the los angeles unified school district
about a month ago they're about uh maybe
80
60 or 70 percent of
uh school staff and teachers vaccinated
the deadline was on monday and by monday
there were 97
of the school staff and teachers
vaccinated so we do believe that the
carrots only work to some regard
lotteries a shot for a shot ice cream
donuts uh at the end of the day mandates
have really moved the dial much more in
the united states so far
goodness i didn't even get a cup of tea
when i had mine um talk to me quickly
before i let you go professor if you
would please uh about those that say you
know what rather than giving these jobs
to kids what the united states and other
developed countries should be doing is
shipping them off to south africa
i think uh
the answer is yes and yes um i think we
can be both
doing
increasing community immunity as well as
uh you know sharing the recipe having
the raw materials to make the vaccines
and uh
having the manpower and the technical
know-how to spread the word i think uh
merck is giving a good example for their
oral um
anti-viral medicine milo perivier that's
where they've shared the recipe with
generic companies they're having a
shared pricing system so i think you
know all hands on deck and you're right
we can't really defeat the virus until
every one of us is vaccinated around the
world
okay professor good to talk to you
thanks for staying up for us in san
francisco this evening thank you
you're welcome keith thank you thank you
thank you we're going to be talking
about that in more detail to the former
prime minister tony blair he's joining
us in the nine o'clock hour here on sky
news this morning now some of the
world's biggest banks are investing in
businesses linked with deforestation
that's according to a new report shared
with sky news helen smith has this
exclusive report
[Music]
behind glassy facades in financial
centers lied deals which determine the
flow of money but there are serious
questions about where some of it goes
and what some of it funds
a new investigation shared exclusively
with sky news shows that tens of
billions of pounds is financing work
like this
banks and asset managers investing
underwriting and loaning to agribusiness
linked to deforestation they tell us
they're green institutions but they just
keep doing it the research team analyzed
70 000 deals struck with 20 of the worst
offending businesses they say many banks
profited to the tune of tens of millions
of pounds they're very good at telling
us how green they are but what we found
is this gaping hole between what they
say in public and what they actually do
so when you follow the money and look at
their revenue streams look at their
actions you realize that they're not as
clean as they say they are
in fact since the paris climate
agreement in 2016 financial institutions
in europe the us and china have made
deals worth 120 billion pounds with
firms linked to tropical deforestation
u.s bank jp morgan was the biggest
lender making deals worth over 7 billion
pounds while in the uk hsbc was the
biggest financer making deals worth over
5 billion
hsbc alone made estimated proceeds of
nearly 30 million pounds from these
deals that's despite a pledge four years
ago to stop financing firms accused of
deforestation
in a statement it said hsbc has exited
is in the process of exiting or has no
banking relationship related to forestry
palmel or cattle with the majority of
entities named in the report
it says it's ended relationships with
customers that don't comply with its
policies and is committed to tackling
deforestation jp morgan declined to
comment there's nothing illegal about
these deals but many banks have pledged
not to make them however there's a
growing argument that self-regulation
hasn't worked and what's needed is a
change in the law
the government's flagship environment
bill is due next week a perfect
opportunity according to some
neil parish tabled an amendment to ban
these type of financial deals but it was
rejected the legislature is always
important because you can then go to
these major banks major companies and
actually say you have acted illegally
you must stop and we can take direct
action but even despite all of that the
government rejected your amendment but
that doesn't stop us till thoughtfully
the government
and i think the government has come a
long way in the environment built
towards the direction we want
cutting down forest not only contributes
to climate change but is devastating to
local communities
cutting off the finance would
substantially cut down the practice
helen and smith sky news
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
the morning will be fine for most after
patchy early rain over southern england
clears but there'll be showers in the
north and west they'll be wintry on
northern hills it will be much colder
than recently with a raw wind in the
north and east bringing coastal gales
the afternoon will bring a few showers
into the midlands but there'll be little
change elsewhere the push of clean cold
air from the northern atlantic means the
air pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will be
low
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now scientists from durham university
have said that infrared light therapy
could potentially help people living
with dementia the study found that the
use of the light could benefit people's
memory motor function and also
processing skills joining us is dr paul
shazzat from derrick university hello to
you doctor thank you for joining us this
sounds amazing tell us about infrared
light therapy
okay so this is a culmination i guess of
20 years
research in my lab uh
with a number of people and lots lots of
people involved actually um it's yeah so
it involves a specific wavelength of
infrared light which we've been studying
like i said for 20 years
uh it's a very
uh key wavelength and it penetrates the
brain
very easily and you can apply it very
easily using a specialized helmet as on
the on the image here and uh it
penetrates her brain and elicits lots of
uh mechanisms biological mechanisms that
are very relevant to both aging and also
uh alzheimer's disease and dementia
it looks pretty funky
um how does it actually work and who who
will benefit from it
uh so the idea well as i said uh it uh
elicits lots of because
aging and alzheimer's disease is a very
complex disease you need a sort of
complex way of of treating
the these and this this light actually
elicits lots of different biological
effects it increases blood flow
it increases the battery function within
cells so it keeps cells
healthy and viable uh it reduces
inflammation it reduces oxidative stress
so it has lots of key mechanisms that
you find in aging and
also
um
yeah in in particularly in alzheimer's
disease so we've tested this now
clinically which is all important
and a couple of studies in in the uk and
in the states
and uh we've shown that actually this
treatment does improve memory but in
particular memory processes uh both in
in middle aged individuals who don't
have dementia but also in alzheimer's
disease
patients mild to moderate alzheimer's
disease it improves quite dramatically
actually the memory of of these of these
individuals over a very short period
eight week treatment uh you can elicit
perhaps a 20 improvement in in memory
which is quite staggering and
actually it's it's as far as we can see
we can't see any sort of
issues in terms of side effects which so
it's a safe potentially effective
treatment but i need to say
sorry can i just ask you professor is it
going to be a preventative treatment as
well
well that's that is that is a potential
definitely a potential and we're looking
at that seriously uh so you know the the
idea potentially could you know start
using it maybe in in middle age and and
yeah as a preventative mechanism i mean
the biology would
fit that you know there is certainly uh
potential for that as well as i mean i'm
mostly focused on on the on the you know
what the disease so alzheimer's disease
in particular potentially parkinson's as
well
uh i'm i'm interested in in helping out
the
well in the uk up to a million people
with alzheimer's disease you know that's
my first goal but yes as a preventative
uh procedure it has possibilities but i
need to emphasize that it's we've done
very short small studies so far so we
need to increase the studies
increase the number of patients and
increase the number of people that uh
so to demonstrate that it would work
across the population if you like
okay professor we must leave it there
but absolutely fascinating stuff
brilliant work over the last two decades
along with some of your colleagues as
you mentioned of course as well and we
look forward to the next steps thank you
so much for joining us this morning no
problem thank you
isn't it great when we speak to very
very clever people who could make a huge
difference to so many of us up and down
the country and indeed around the world
uh also to come more on that warning
from doctors that the government is
being willfully negligent by refusing to
bring back tougher covered restrictions
ahead of the winter months we heard uh
from the health minister earlier today
and he says at this stage there is spare
capacity in the national health service
the government is not unduly alarmed but
what should be happening is that more
people should be coming forward for
their boosters and they say you can book
that online
[Music]